foreign
everybody there are fresh Revelations
over the former Health secretary Matt
Hancock's handling of the covid pandemic
The Daily Telegraph has published more
of his WhatsApp messages appearing to
reveal a dispute with the then education
secretary sir Gavin Williamson over
whether to close schools in the early
stages of the pandemic with sir Gavin
accusing teachers of looking for an
excuse not to work during the pandemic a
spokesperson for Matt Hancock responded
saying these are partial accounts
obviously spawn with an agenda they show
map was focused throughout on saving
lives the right place for a full
assessment is the inquiry
well let's get more on this um should we
no no government minister to speak to
this morning tomorrow this is not going
to stop here is it no absolutely not and
today these lockdown files are
telegraph's cache of messages from Matt
Hancock reveal a bitter clash between Mr
Hancock and the education secretary
Gavin Williamson you'll remember back in
January 2021 Gavin Williamson had fought
for weeks to keep schools open Matt
Hancock talks in these messages about
fighting a rear guard action to make
sure schools were closed I'm sure all
parents will remember those chaotic days
when Boris Johnson went on television to
say schools are going to be opening in
January 2021 with that second wave of
covert Gathering pace and just 24 hours
later a complete reverse ferret when he
said they would in fact be closed for
more than six weeks now what these
messages reveal is that Gavin Williamson
thought he'd won the argument on schools
in fact Matt Hancock went to the prime
minister's Chief of Staff to say that
this was a policy car crash in those
messages and in the end it was Gavin
Williamson who had to in Matt Hancock's
words eat Humble Pie Mr Williamson has
spoken to the Telegraph and said that it
was an absolutely crushing blow that
schools had to close and he still
wonders if he should have resigned over
it what we also see in his extraordinary
messages I mean alongside Boris Johnson
having statistics explained to him by
Dominic Cummings we see Mr Williamson
criticizing teachers this goes back to
the first look down in 2020 saying they
were looking for an excuse to avoid
having to teach when he was asking Matt
Hancock to supply them with PPE and on
that point we have some some tweets from
Gavin Williamson last night saying that
he was referring in fact to teaching
unions he says further to reports in the
Telegraph and other outlets I wish to
clarify these messages were about some
unions and not teachers as demonstrated
in the exchange I was responding
regarding unions I have the utmost
respect for teachers who work tirelessly
to support students so extraordinary
messages giving us an Insight really
into how policy he was made in these
heady days of the pandemic okay tomorrow
afternoon thank you in other news the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex have been
asked to vacate their UK home just weeks
after the release of Harry's Memoir
spare the couple of confirmed a
spokesperson for Harry and Megan said a
request has been made for them to give
up Frogmore Cottage close to Windsor
Castle the movie is said to have been
sanctioned by the king and will remove
their remaining foothold in the UK
further weakening ties with the rest of
the royal family let's get more on this
should be from Frogmore Cottage Rachel's
standing by for us when do they have to
do this by Rachel good morning
good morning K well it's really
significant the timing of this decision
confirmed last night by the sussexes
because of course it comes just weeks
after the publication of Harry's
explosive highly damning but also
best-selling Memoir spare in which he
lobbed a series of metaphorical grenades
across the Atlantic towards his family
including allegations at the Prince
William physically attacked him and also
he called the queen consort his
stepmother a dangerous woman accusing
her of having leaked stories about
himself and William to the Press him and
his wife Megan were gifted Frogmore
Cottage back in 2020 they've been living
in California they were gifted the
cottage sorry for their wedding in 2018
they were gifted the cottage for their
wedding and of course we know that
they've been living in California for
the last few years ever since that Royal
Rift in the past they've barely been
back to Frogmore Cottage over the past
few years but this news that they've
been asked to move out really
significant further damaging the rift
between the Royals since the publication
of that Memoir spare it's reported that
Prince Charles has sanctioned this
decision and that perhaps he's
considering giving it to prince Andrew
his disgraced younger brother who's a
current property is much larger than
Frogmore Cottage of course this raises
questions will the sussexes be invited
to the coronation and if they did get an
invite or would they even come
okay for now thank you interesting that
um the decision is for after uh the
coronation so perhaps they'll come for
that who knows time will tell as they
say please searching for the baby of
constance Martin and her partner Mark
Gordon say a body has been found they
continue to question the couple who were
arrested in Brighton on Monday after
going on the run in January they've been
arrested on suspicion of gross
negligence manslaughter the search near
Brighton for the two-month-old is over
after police revealed they'd find
remains in Woodland the parents went
missing for two months but were found on
Monday being questioned as I said on
suspicion of gross negligence
manslaughter
public inquiry into 2017's Manchester
Arena bombing will publish its third and
final report today it will include
findings on whether MI5 and
counter-terrorism police could have
prevented the attack MI5 first
identified the bomber Salman avedi as a
subject of Interest back in March of
2014 but closed the case four months
later MI5 looked at obesity again in
October of 2015 after he visited a
convicted terrorist in jail that case
was closed later the same day
abedi and his brother Hashem made
several trips to Libya in the three
years before the attack about he
returned to the UK on the 18th of May
four days later he detonated his
homemade bomb at Manchester Arena
killing himself and 22 others and
injured hundreds more into member
Rasheed hasmel
its mission is to keep our country safe
but the decisions made within the walls
of MI5 in the months and years leading
up to one of the country's deadliest
Terror attacks are in the spotlight
Salman abadi was the subject the
security service had eyes on for a
number of years but just days before a
high-level meeting to discuss what
threats he posed his homemade suicide
bomb murdered 22 people at a pop concert
[Music]
just eight years old Safi rusas was one
of those victims the youngest life taken
her father believes those tasked with
protecting her failed
Simon the baby should have been stopped
before he got to that Arena and that's
in my first job an MI5 know the threat
the no
the what these people do and don't do
they know where to look and where not to
look and they are more prepared than
what Manchester was that night so MI5
for me have got blood on the hands after
almost three years since it began the
Manchester Arena inquiry will publish
its third and final report it will focus
on the radicalization of the abedi
family and we'll crucially address what
was known by the security service about
Salman and his links with convicted
terrorists
and despite MI5 receiving highly
relevant intelligence about a baby twice
in the months prior to his attack they
treated it as non-terrorist criminality
a kick in the teeth for those who lost
loved ones obsessed with C
and it's an unhealthy organization that
shies away from any kind of scrutiny and
the question we've been asking is is
this about National Security or national
embarrassment
it's a question that may well be
answered but won the government already
has a response to
my experience of working with all of the
intelligence agencies in this country is
we're incredibly well served of course
there are always lessons to learn and
they are very open to that but actually
they serve this country uh by net by
definition unseen and we are very lucky
to have such professional intelligence
agencies in this country
but for the families of the 22 victims
who've remained at the very center of
this public inquiry knowing all of this
could have been prevented maybe the
toughest news since that tragic night
itself into man Rashid Sky News
Manchester
emergency workers have searched late
into the night for survivors and bodies
after a train Collision in northern
Greece killed at least 43 people and
anger has boiled over in Athens where a
protesters set up the off set to Fire
and set upon the offices of Greece's
rail operator we want to know more about
this start with the crash happen near
Larissa Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons is there for us um hello to you
a lot of anger developing there despite
the transport secretary resigning
yesterday
yeah he resigned the Prime Minister was
here and saying this was a unspeakable
and unbelievable crash but that is the
evidence that you can see behind me that
something utterly catastrophic happened
in the past few minutes we think they
have just pulled another body uh from
that wreckage we know that the the
number of dead stands at 43 and I think
like common consent that is certain to
rise possibly substantially the anger
that we saw on the streets in Athens the
protest outside the Hellenic train
company is being replicated I think
across this country because while this
is an appalling shocking Crush you can't
think of anything more fundamentally
worse on a train system than two
Services crushing into each other head
on at the speed well certainly the
passenger service going at over 100
miles an hour it is not an enormous
surprise as recently as a as a month ago
one of the train unions was predicting
that something awful could happen on
these services uh even the rail
regulator said that this service is open
to human error and why because of I
think everyone agrees a long-term
chronic lack of investment uh really
really substandard signaling systems and
somehow that may have led to this
Dreadful Crush station master from
Larissa has been arrested and will be
charged officially today with multiple
counts of manslaughter
thanks a lot
fractured East-West relations are
hanging over what's shaping up to be a
contentious meeting of G20 foreign
ministers in New Delhi Neville's
standing by for us this morning last
time the Russians were there a lot of
NATO countries walked out
that's correct there are two blocks here
now the East and the West with the East
being led by Russia now backed by China
the West with the U.S and Britain being
leading the way well the the India is
very concerned about the whole meeting
being overrun by the Ukraine issue and
they want other issues to be talked
about but it is unlikely so because the
main question now is about the Ukraine
war and uh and America and Britain wants
this to be discussed thorough
okay for now thanks very much thank you
bulletinubu has been declared the winner
of a highly contentious presidential
election in Nigeria but this is being
disputed by his Rivals been talking
about this all week uh yuster is
standing by for us now what's the latest
today Easter good morning
good morning Kay in the capital seems
very calm things seem to relatively be
going back to normal after a very
intense year of campaigning from
candidates across different parties but
the labor party the one of the main
opposition parties has decided to
contest the election results in the
courts within the stipulator 21 days so
we will see over the next period more uh
more updates on what's happening but
essentially the people we've spoken to
here have said that every election so
far in Nigeria has been settled in the
courts and that they expect that the
ruling party will come out Victorious
the labor party themselves told us that
they expected the courts to rule in
favor of the ruling party that they were
not partial but they're still putting up
a fight they're not accepting this win
the Bola matanubu has received a
certificate cemented his win and is now
in the capital that will soon become his
home okay Mr for now thank you
in other news actually let's bring in
the defense committee chair Tobias
Elwood Heights good to see you thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning lots to talk about should we
talk uh first of all about what's
happening in um India and the fact that
last time uh Russia addressed the
Western leaders um they all walked out
they did indeed it shows the I think the
difference between uh the support that
Russia is getting but also what's
happening across the world
we Face a dilemma as we lean in and
support Ukraine a lot of countries
condemning what Russia's done but only
34 countries actually had sanctions
against Russia so we need to Rally other
nations around the world to lean in to
support a Ukraine and recognize that
this isn't just about Ukraine anymore
that's where the theater of war is
actually taking place this is about a
new ideology or rather an old ideology
of Russia expanding its influence in
Eastern Europe but more worryingly a an
alignment between what Russia and what
China actually wants to do in
challenging our International
rules-based order we go into a very
dangerous space when a permanent member
of the United Nations security Council
invades another state and another
permanent member China does nothing
about it does not condemn it and then
the other three permanent members France
Britain and the United States are not
exactly aligned as what we should do so
lots of big questions there uh
leadership required but also a
commitment to see this through in 2023
well the other three less aligned aren't
they as far as Russia is concerned you
know they've got a lot of questions to
answer when it comes to China they've
gone to Russia and said we are trying to
help broker a peace deal
as a result should they be going now to
Ukraine to try to do the same no appease
deal right now is supporting Russia
because Russia owns one-fifth of Ukraine
so if we allow this conflict to freeze
now that's to Russia's benefit and then
Ukraine isn't able to have that
Sovereign identity and it won't this
economy won't be able to work in the
future it won't have that long-term
security guarantee that we need for
peace in Eastern Europe and what Russia
will do is simply calm down regroup
re-arm and do this all again this is why
there's something much much bigger going
on we've entered a very dark chapter in
our history and we really haven't woken
up to that yet so countries such as
India and I would say South Africa even
Mexico and so forth not standing up to
Russia perhaps in the way that we would
expect them to
um I think is is a worrying a reflection
of where we are in the world are you
saying the fighting needs to continue
for now I'm afraid what we need to do is
use 2023 to conclude this we need to
lean into this give Ukraine the weapon
systems they need Russia is in this for
the Long Tall their ability to endure
hardship is far greater than the West so
if we are to actually stand up for
democracies yes you're right whether you
know Britain United States and France
are more less in alignment but we're not
utilizing nato in the way that we should
do we're not actually giving the weapon
system it took us an entire year to get
the main battle tanks there and we're
having a similar debate of hesitance to
deal with air power as well if Ukraine
is to ensure that the West is rallying
around uh Ukraine it needs to gain
terrain to gain terrain you have to
punch through the Russian defenses
that's where main battle tanks come in
and to give main battle tanks the
advantage they need the top color they
need air power they need fast Jets well
that's not going to happen anytime soon
certainly as far as the UK is concerned
we've heard that time and time again
from our defense secretary and then we
turned and then we'd so then the penny
dropped and then we slid across
Challenger two tanks which weren't
necessarily appropriate but symbolically
they then opened up others and that's
brilliant leadership
why does turkey not want Finland and or
Sweden to join NATO again this goes to
perhaps the alliances that we're seeing
around the world turkey is very much uh
embedded with Russia from a military
perspective they buy some of their
weapon systems they got thrown out of
the F-35 fast jet project for that exact
reason even though they're a member of
NATO and it just shows you perhaps the
the limits of what NATO can actually do
now we've created something called The
Joint expeditionary Force which you
could call Nato light this is 10 Eastern
European countries plus Britain that
looks after the high North if we're to
provide security guarantees for Ukraine
I would invite Ukraine to join uh The
Joint expeditionary force and that
allows a kit and equipment and support
to come far far faster than what's been
provided by NATO because of the very
reason you said that both turkey and
indeed Hungary are just hesitant to do
anything that might upset
um might upset Russia and indeed Putin
okay and to that end we're hearing about
a fence being built again that was going
to be it's going to be symbolic but it's
um it's illustrating where Russia might
go next well this is the problems that
we have is that this isn't just about
Ukraine we must recognize that had we
not provided the weapon systems to
Ukraine early on they would have pushed
on and absolutely attacked Moldova and
then pops it into the Balkans as well
and then there'll be a huge threat to
the baltics too this is so so much
bigger this is Russia returning to type
wanting to expand its sphere of
influence and as I said all the more
complicated because the big clash of the
century is between the United States and
China and what China is doing is
watching very carefully the precedent we
set in dealing with the fire in Ukraine
okay talk to me about these WhatsApp
messages that we're seeing in the Daily
Telegraph suggestions at sir Gavin
Williamson who I know that you have
worked with when he at the ministry of
Defense saying that teachers didn't want
to work during the pandemic and what was
actually happening at of government at
the time these are absolutely important
questions which is why it's so critical
that we have a proper inquiry what we've
seen now in the last few days is the
Daily Telegraph get an immense amount of
data my concern is that we're going to
get this drip feed as we do when the
status sort of comes out there are
people wanting to provide their angle of
their story I do hope that the inquiry
is able to wrap up and provide its
conclusions soon because it's so
important that we learn lessons from
this there could easily be another
pandemic in the future mistakes were
made there was no rule book there was no
blueprint for us to follow uh in in the
past as to how we respond to this virus
but ultimately challenges were made and
I think accepting some mistakes were
made as well the idea that we sort of
picked through individual things I can't
really comment because I don't know the
details more generally is the fact that
without leaving the detail aside what
does it say about a former Health
secretary who gives up hundred thousand
WhatsApp private messages many of them
one to one end-to-end encrypted I'm sure
there's a data protection issues there
um to a journalist who he knows is a
covered lockdown denier what does that
say about somebody at the top of
government
I I the way you articulate the question
I think speaks volumes it's not in my
character to you know want to start
making personal comments like that Matt
Hancock has chosen his new path of where
he wants to go and how he wants to do it
uh I just hope the inquiry getting back
to politics and the very important
questions that many many uh people
across the country including your
viewers who want to know you know what
happened what happened with in the care
homes with the decisions surrounding
those with loved ones that affect them
that's the details we want we don't know
the exact truth because this is one side
of the story and another all very very
serious all the more important that the
inquiry is made it could be with the
Care Homes just to focus on that for a
second that perhaps the inquiry could do
a limited study on that and produce that
much much earlier I'm worried with these
inquiries that they drag on sometimes
for years and that will be I think you
know it's unhelpful we need to get the
results now provide and I think people
want answers as soon as you circumvented
my questions so I'll let you off on that
one but I suppose I'll ask it in a
different way which is would you release
all your WhatsApp messages no I wouldn't
I think there's I mean I think that was
done for personal gain and I'm sorry
about that you know a bigger picture
look what has happened this last Suite
with our conservative party for the
first time we've Illustrated some
statecraft that I'm not seen for quite
some time that's what the electorate
wants to see Richie sunac managed to
land that deal which showed what happens
when you have leadership determination
Vision Focus bridge building rather than
the bombastic
partisan aggression that we've had in
the past we're starting to regroup you
saw that in the chamber yesterday in
prime minister's questions that's what
we should be illustrating a new culture
of wanting to do what's best for the
nation so all these stories about what's
happened in the past now you know I
think there are distractions to where we
want to go we have a possibility of
winning the next general election and we
need greater discipline and focus that's
what the nation wants to see yeah um
apparently he did it to um because she
was Ghost writing his book A book that
sold 4 000 copies is that right I didn't
know that yeah well I put a smile on
your face thanks for joining us as
always thanks very much look at the
papers for you know the telegraph leads
with the latest from Cox WhatsApp
messages as we're hearing there from the
defense committee chairman it's a
distraction from what the prime minister
is trying to do it's a dispute with the
education secretary Gavin Williamson to
close schools during the pandemic that's
what they're focusing on this morning
Guardian also leads on Hancock's saying
ministers are concerned about the effect
these leaks will have on the official
covert inquiry
Daily Mirror calls it the tragic
betrayal the Metro also leads on the
leaks
the times reports Millions will be
helped helped to come off
antidepressants and painkillers to
tackle addiction
the eye reports on bird flu and the
possibility of vaccinating chickens in
the UK to stop bird flu spreading to
humans
and the sun reports on the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex being asked to vacate
Frogmore Cottage in Windsor
okay a quick look at the express as well
then there you go talking about that
eviction as well quick look at the
weather for you
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days will stay mainly dry but
the Northeast will turn colder over the
weekend with chances of wintry showers
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
snapshot of the world's changing climate
let's have a look we got it climate
dashboard there we are Nicole a lot of
gas Renewables are coming up a little
bit that's how much hotter we are since
1880 and this is how many millions of
tons of CO2 in real time is being put
into the atmosphere
remember we're asking you uh what you
think the Queen's uh favorite book is
it's world book day today she's spoken
about the importance of reading at an
early age and how she's read to her
grandchildren hoping to make them
bookworms Camilla also revealed her
favorite childhood tale during a chat
with children's Laureate Joseph coella
to Mark World Book Day
I ended up probably being a sort of pony
bad child with black beauty which I
hauled over night after night after
night and that was
well world book day is of course a
chance for children to dress up as their
favorite Story characters Camilla is a
long time supporter of book trust and
took over as the Charities Patron in
2011 from the late Duke of Edinburgh I
suppose a question for you guys today is
um world book day are you sending your
kids
um dressed up uh as their favorite
characters I'm guessing there'll be a
lot of Harry Potter and some Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory as well I'm
guessing what are your children dressing
up as today for world book day perhaps
you could let us know you can tweet us
if you would like to at K Burley or use
the hashtag if you prefer kbertley and
we will share them with our viewers a
little bit later on to the Middle East
now Israel's government is under
pressure from its closest Ally after the
Finance Minister called for a
Palestinian Village to be erased the U.S
state Department spokesperson Ned price
says the comments were repugnant and
discussed okay let's get more should we
Alistair standing by for us in Jerusalem
this morning what's all this about
Alistair good morning
foreign
is a Palestinian town in the West Bank
it was the scene of very heavy writing
over the weekend when a few hundred
Jewish settlers came into the town in
Revenge for the murder of two young
Israelis over the weekend and they burnt
a number of cars burnt houses a lot of
Palestinian families had to be rescued
and one Palestinian man was killed as a
result of the violence the IDF the
Israeli military have admitted that they
underestimated the situation and got
their tactics wrong and the commander of
the area described it as a pogram now
bezel al-smotrich is the Finance
Minister he's one of the most senior
figures in Benin netanyahu's government
and yesterday on stage at an event he
said that he believes the village of
hawara should be wiped out he did say
that shouldn't be done by civilians it
should be done by the Israeli government
but it's incredibly incendiary uh
remarks in the United States have
reacted very strongly to it the state
department spokesperson Ned price uh you
quoted some of him there he said I want
to be very clear about this these
comments were irresponsible they were
repugnant they were disgusting and just
as we condemned Palestinian incitement
to violence we condemn these provocative
remarks that also amount to incitement
to violence now there's been no
condemnation from Benin Netanyahu
himself or anyone else in the cabinet
but they are coming under a lot of
pressure uh America they don't like the
Americans getting too involved in what
goes on here but America is a very very
valuable and much needed Ally for the
Israelis and they are now putting the
Israeli government Under Pressure to
tone down the language but also
backtrack from those words by the
Finance Minister okay for now thank you
while Sky News has been told that a bird
flu strain that infected a girl and her
father in Cambodia has mutated to more
easily spread to humans the who says
it's reviewing its Global risk
assessment in light of what it calls
worrying developments our science and
medical correspondent Thomas More has
more
just how concerned should we be about
the two human cases of bird flu in
Cambodia we know they occurred in the
south of the country in prevent Province
an 11 year old girl died and her father
also tested positive for the h5n1 virus
but he's well genetic testing identified
the girls virus as an endemic variant
called
2321c but the scientists leading the
analysis has now told Sky News that the
bird flu virus had mutations that helped
it adapt to human cells
there are some indications that
um you know this virus has gone through
a human so what we have to understand is
that when a virus gets into a new host
they are very promiscuous they change
very quickly and they do adapt
but that doesn't mean the virus can
spread between people at least not yet
it latches on to a type of cell receptor
which is only found deep down in our
lungs for it to transmit easily between
people it has to mutate to Target a
different receptor found on cells in our
nasal passages that's what regular
winter flu does the cells are not only
easier to infect but a cloud of virus is
released with every breath but Dr
Carlson warns the world must closely
track the virus and work on test kits
and vaccines just in case it changes
it is concerning that it's gone Global
so quickly and I think the entire
influenza Community as well as the
public health and Animal Health
communities are quite concerned about it
um obviously
in the UK
um in all of Europe as well as North
America South America
um there's been massive poultry
infections there's been spillovers into
mammals
um and each one of those spillovers into
mammals is a concern
here the UK Health Security Agency
reported a human case of bird flu in
January 2022 and so far this winter
there have been more than 3 000
exposures to the H5 N1 virus and people
working closely with sick Birds none of
them tested positive Health officials
are also analyzing a small number of
samples taken from patients with
flu-like symptoms to check the virus
isn't spreading below the radar it's not
just Cambodia a risk the next pandemic
could start anywhere
and of course we'll keep an eye on that
story for you meantime
um I want to talk to you about what's
happening with the inquiry into the
Manchester Arena bombing which will be
published later on today 22 people were
killed and hundreds were injured Robbie
Potter was just 10 feet away from the
suicide bomber when he set off his
explosives he's with us now hi Robbie um
how are you
uh good morning you're okay
I am okay I wondered how you were
feeling about the report being published
later on today bringing back lots of
memories for you
unfortunately yes you will do yes
perhaps you can tell me about what
happened to you on the night
unfortunately um I received nuts to my
shoulders one through my heart my lungs
uh and both kneecaps and whilst in
multiple oral injuries
talk to me about
um I think you were just what 10 feet or
so away were you from the bomber yeah it
was very close yes yeah what did you
notice about him at the time
um he obviously had quite a big backpack
on but looked like someone was looking
for students but Looking Back Now
obviously look very nervous
yeah and then you found yourself in a
position where you were severely injured
how long did it take for people to come
and help you
um I believe with over half an hour
I was lucky because the business
corporate with Brilliance they'd send me
over tried to stop the blood username so
many AC shapes it was supposed
yeah what do you hope what do you hope
that the report finds later on today
more the truth out
and Aquatica the security way in the
build up to it but not taken away from
the fact that the people did this and it
won't be really going to concentrate on
yeah do you feel that during the course
of the inquiry that your voice and the
voice of others that was injured that
were injured has been heard by those
that are writing the report
uh now we've also saw statements in
we've had no contact or
no I honestly yeah yeah I understand
that and how's life been like since
just along rebuilding
obviously can't let them beat you so I
mean I'm still obviously you haven't
seen But now
but you know I'm back up on my face I
can't play rugby again which is a big
killer but yeah
you know there's a lot of people a lot
worse or very a lot worse than what
happens to me it's worth to be thankful
for that
so what does a normal life look like for
you now what would you do on a normal
day
I have to go a lot earlier I have to do
a lot of stretching move obviously take
a lot of tablets and fortunes for a
rattle a bit
um but I said I can't look back today
I'm very very lucky to hear because
excellent way for what the surgeon did
in the NHS but also the most ambitious
people will actually saved me on that
day
and have you managed to keep in touch
with any of the people that were also
caught up in this time yeah we have a
few different groups not like whatever
and we seems to get in touch many
languages and obviously around the
anniversary people are just trying to
move on so how things are back with your
mind
and where will you be later on to find
out uh what the report has suggested
uh to be honest you're probably gonna
take the dog for a walk
put into language so we can actually
understand
yeah I know it's going to be a tough day
for you rugby so um thanks for taking
the time to join us this morning enjoy
the walk with the dog and um just take
it easy today thank you she's very
welcome thank you very much thanks a lot
looking at some other headlines for you
this morning and secure stammer is
considering recruiting senior civil
servants Sue gray to be his new Chief of
Staff as gray is of course best known
for her report into lockdown breaking
parties in Downing Street labor says the
process is ongoing and so far nobody has
been offered the job
MPS say a loophole which allows sex
offenders to change their name and evade
Justice must be closed between 2019 and
2022 there were around 11 and a half
thousand prosecutions of sex offenders
for failing to notify police about a
change in their personal information
such as their name
there's been a 66 rise in children and
young people getting urgent treatment
for eating disorders in England since
2019 that's according to the Royal
College of psychiatrists which says all
English regions are failing to meet
targets for when patients should be seen
because services are flooded with
referrals
four Spears which were brought to
England more than 250 years ago are to
be returned to Australia they were among
many taken from an indigenous Camp by
Captain Cook and his crew after landing
at what's now Botany Bay in Sydney
the local indigenous people regard the
spears as National Treasures 9. a
portrait by Pablo Picasso of his
daughter Maya sold last night at auction
four
18 million pounds the piece filled with
exuberant color whittled was painted in
1938 when mayor just two and a half at
the time the auction at Sotheby's was
the first time the work has gone under
the hummus since 1999 when it sold for
3.7 Millions Johnny versace's collection
of uh 25 Picasso works it was part of
that
yeah
and some quick news uh about us Sky News
has won the Royal Television Awards news
channel of the year for the sixth
consecutive year the judges praised our
impressive range of coverage strong
presentation creative production and
commitment to reporting the issues that
most uh that matter most to the audient
and chief correspondent Stuart Ramsey
was named Network TV journalist of the
year his reporting from Ukraine last
year included dramatic footage of him
and his team coming under Fire and being
forced to run for safety as bullets
peppered their vehicle
staying in Ukraine where evidence
continues to emerge of alleged Russian
war crimes which Moscow denies in the
southern city of Kirsten recently
recaptured from Russian forces there are
indications that rooms in some buildings
were used as torture chambers the human
rights lawyer Wayne gordash is leading a
team investigating war crimes in Ukraine
he is in Kiev and joins us now hello she
thanks for joining us on the program
tell us what you discovered
well we are supporting the prosecution
and the prosecution are doing the
investigation and what they've uncovered
is evidence of up to 20 detention
centers they've investigated two of them
with real thoroughness and
um can also investigate some of the
connections between the detention
centers and the Russian government
so what we see is a system of detention
and brutality where hundreds of people
disappeared and were tortured and at
least 400 of them are missing and at
least uh 400 of them are suspected have
been uh killed so what we have is really
a small part of the overall criminal
plan being revealed in her song
do we know how do we know who was
running these sites and how were they
first discovered
beg your pardon my dog is just uh could
you repeat the question it was on this
show no problem with dogs not at all
just talk to me about
um how you discovered these sites and
who potentially was running them
well the prosecution discovered them
through essentially interviewing
Witnesses uh victims of these detention
centers the ones who managed to escape
or their family members and what we're
talking about is a broad range of people
ranging from those who uh were connected
to the military or the security but not
just them journalists human rights
activists volunteers family members of
those who were suspected have been
involved with the military or the
security services of Ukraine this was
effectively a system which was designed
to take out any resistance to the
overall criminal plan and the overall
criminal plan was designed to
essentially subjugate the remainder of
the population and extinguish identity
and that means removing any trace of
Ukrainian identity from the educational
curriculum from the road signs
destruction of cultural artifacts and so
on and so forth
and what we also see is financial links
and this is what uh shows a clear link
other than the system which is uh
appears to be uniform across detention
centers you have these clear Financial
links back to Russia and of course you
also have the those who are involved in
attention centers from the Russian FSB
to local FSB to the Russian prison
service and so on and so forth so
there's plenty of pieces of evidence
which point I mean
irrefutably I would say towards the
Russian State funding these detention
centers planning them designing how they
should work
what are the survivors been telling you
about what happened to them
well if you disappeared into one of
these detention centers life became
extremely Grim we're talking about
electrocutions talking about sexual
violence ranging from electrocution of
genitals to rape to threats of rape
we're talking about water boarding we're
talking about various types of
suffocation
and we're talking about a system within
her somewhere anybody could disappear
into these detention centers and it
didn't matter in fact whether they were
in fact connected to the Ukrainian
government What mattered was in an
increasingly paranoid and brutal
environment that the Russian occupiers
considered that to be the case this was
lawlessness on steroids
is this confirmation of
um genocide by Russia
I would say it looks very close if you
have a criminal plan which is baked into
that plan is war crimes and crimes
against humanity which is clear this is
the Russian military campaign
if you go into subjugate population and
take away from them what they fiercely
hold on to their identity you can't do
that without war crimes and crimes
against humanity that is why we see such
a widespread and systematic uh use of
crimes against civilians in in Ukraine
however what if that fails if that fails
there's only one direction that that
plan goes into which is the physical
destruction which is at the heart of a
genocidal plan so the Russian plan is to
essentially subjugate they will do that
through violence they will achieve a
cultural extinguish they will extinguish
culture if they can but if it fails I
think with her some what we see is the
level of Destruction Elevate and
escalate to such a a a level that we're
talking about very close to if not
indeed actual genocide
uh how does this progress what happens
next
well the investigations uh proceed the
uh Ukrainian prosecution the Hearthstone
prosecutors are working tirelessly with
not enough resources it has to be said
but they continue to map what is an
unprecedented volume of crimes
and then what happens is once that's
mapped at the ground level
then the hard work of building the cases
towards the upper political and Military
leadership begins and I think that's
what we're trying to help the
prosecution with because they're
overwhelmed with so many crimes on the
ground but the real challenge is to
build these cases upwards and to see how
far they go
okay uh good to talk to you thanks very
much and you for joining us thank you
quick look at the weather for United
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
next few days will stay mainly dry but
the Northeast will turn colder over the
weekend with the chance of wintry shower
Central Parts we'll have a fairly mild
but dull rush hour with a little rain in
places while the North and South will be
sunnier with the frost in the
countryside
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
let's return to our top story The
Fallout from Matt Hancock's leaked
WhatsApp message is which shed light on
his handling of the pandemic earlier
this hour I spoke to conservative MP
Tobias Elwood about them
would you release all your WhatsApp
messages no I wouldn't I think that's I
mean I think that was done for personal
gain and I'm sorry about that you know a
bigger picture look what has happened
this last week with our conservative
party for the first time we've
Illustrated some statecraft that I'm not
seen for quite some time that's what the
electorate wants to see Richie sunac
managed to land that deal which showed
what happens when you have leadership
determination Vision Focus bridge
building rather than the bombastic
partisan aggression that we've had in
the past we're starting to regroup you
saw that in the chamber yesterday in
prime minister's questions that's what
we should be illustrating a new culture
of wanting to do what's best for the
nation so all these stories about what's
happened in the past now you know I
think are a distractions to where we
want to go
we're on a spokesperson for Matt Hancock
responded saying these are partial
accounts obviously spun with an agenda
they show was focused throughout on
saving lives the right place for a full
assessment is the inquiry and this was
Gavin Williamson's response to the story
in the telegraph this morning further
reports in the Telegraph and other
outlets I wish to clarify that these
messages were about some unions and not
teachers as demonstrated in the exchange
I was responding regarding unions I have
the utmost respect for teachers who work
tirelessly to support students